taste really refers to for sense of
really five I suppose sensitivities and
that sweet sour salt bitter for
well-known ones and a relatively new
taste sensation called umami at least
new in in the West why are we born with
the ability to already like certain
flavors or do we develop them over our
lifespan
that's an interesting discussions taste
is ever-changing taste this objective it
has to do with your own pet it I'm
watching my daughter who's ten months
old begin to eat things and I'm watching
her brain work as she tastes something
for the first time when she tastes sweet
thing she tends to well my main reason
for eating local food is that local food
tastes better caviar is I don't know if
it's an expended a store an expensive
taste understanding what's organic or
natural or or appropriate for a
situation is what what people sort of
define is taste I know bad taste but to
know get bad taste you have to have know
all the rules of good taste of course
you have to have a certain background
great taste is also understanding that
you can't define it fashion can take the
worst thing that everybody threw out and
make everybody want to spend too much
money and buy it again that's a magic
trick that's or it isn't it that's not
the edge taste it's brilliance if they
ask me the tastemakers of any generation
have always been the people who push the
envelope you can't have fun with bad
taste unless you know the rules to break
you